yeah so you used to upload daily on that
garbage internet i sure did oh my god
and that's why my computer exploded i'll
get like burnt out from that
i think i would like hate i mean i did
get burnt out
after like two and a half years of doing
that because
i quit let's plays a week before i moved
to japan
i remember i remember when you quit that
and i thought like good
good yeah oh everyone everyone was like
good you should you should have done
that
and i think i did it at the perfect time
because that was just around the time
like
early 2015 that was around the time when
gaming was kind of starting to dip
yeah like just overall that's when
youtube kind of shafted all of gaming
youtube right i was like no more
spotlight for you oh yeah that's around
yeah 2015. yeah which like speaking
about that have you guys
like in your youtube careers ever
properly experienced burnout
oh yeah like when when when was the last
time you guys experienced burnout
pro last time i experienced like proper
burnout was maybe
this was back before i was living with
aki right um and i was just living
on my own yeah and uh and yeah i just
had like
a moment like maybe for like half a year
where i was just constantly like all i
was thinking about was like all right
what's the next video what's the next
yeah i'm gonna keep one upping myself
and like just coming up with ideas
because even back then i think i was
maybe uploading like once every
three days yeah or something so not not
as intense as daily but it's still
pretty [ __ ] intense that's right
especially because now i wasn't doing
let's plays anymore i was doing like
straight up like
i was writing a script every [ __ ] day
right right so
that [ __ ] burnt me out like a hell of a
lot and there was like a point where i
was legitimately like should i just like
stop like should i just stop youtube for
a while
yeah but then i was like nah ain't worth
it yeah
i mean i think a lot of people the
viewers heard a lot about like
the mystical youtube burnout and what it
means like what what are they like can
you like try and explain
at this point when i i'm sure like for
like a viewer
hearing of him fearing hearing burnout
was just like oh let's just get that off
the youtuber checklist
yeah it's kind of just kind of kind of
just become a cliche now it's like oh
you reached burnout okay
okay it's like all right see you in a
couple of days
you'll be over it so yeah like people
think that youtuber burnout is just like
uh
like i don't know what was me yeah kind
of a woe is me like a very
privileged first world problem but i i
think like it's just another form of
like create a burnout right where
and if you've never experienced burnout
in your life or create a burnout
artist's block is another word for it
yeah it's essentially where
you want to do something and you want to
make something but you either have
no motivation or no inspiration to do
whatever or both sometimes yeah
you're just like man i really want to
get a video out i know i need to get a
video
out i want to be creative i just don't
know what to do yeah
and i have no motivation for it yeah i
think there's one person who reached
bernard recently then
they made a statement about it and it
like it like hit me hard because
um so the author of tower of god
recently went on hiatus for like
for like an indefinite period of time so
we don't know he has he hasn't said
i'm gonna be away for this long he
actually just wrote like a really really
long post
um just detailing that keys just had no
breaks for this entire like time during
tower of gods
and i remember there was this one line
that really hit me which was i think he
said
i i didn't know whether i was working to
upload or uploading to work or
no no what i didn't know whether i was
living to upload or upload to live
you know what i mean and i'm i'm just
like dude i totally get that man yeah
yeah
because there's there are times during
burnout where you're just like man what
what am i doing what am i doing am i
even enjoying this anymore
so i mean to explain to the viewers how
how do you like get into burnout like
how do you like how does it what does it
mean what does it feel like
like and how does it start it happens in
so many different ways i feel really
depends on the person but like
you know a common thing that would
happen is like for example
um like if you uploaded like four or
five videos that are like
absolute bangers right it's just like
boom views boom views born views and
then
after that really good streak you have
another streak
but in the opposite direction yeah of
like oh that one bombed oh that one
bombed even
oh that one bombed even harder yeah and
you start to lose
self motivation and like like you you
start to i don't know
it's really hard to explain isn't it it
kind of just happened like you don't
realize
create a burnout has started until
you're deep in creativity yeah yeah
it's it's really hard to see the early
signs of creative burnout sometimes it's
just
you just wake up and you just do a job
and then eventually like
five months down the line you're like
man i've just been feeling the same
exactly the same this entire five months
and i'm just not getting anything new
out of this
i'm i'm sure it's i'm sure like most
people who just
work normal jobs get it as well with
their own job where they just kind of
feel like like hmm
do i like this or like i know a lot of
people don't like what they do and they
just do it to survive because they don't
have a choice right i mean we're very
lucky that
we do something that is most people
would say it's pretty fun
right yeah and it's very and no doubt it
is oh it's
definitely like the like it it's it's a
very hard job
and i'm not in like any manual intensive
kind of way
yeah no not being like yeah we're
working so [ __ ] hard
it's a hard job like mentally but still
definitely by far like the best job i've
ever had oh yeah i caught i couldn't
think of a job that would give me this
much freedom no i wouldn't
replace this foreign which is why we
haven't quit but yeah in terms of
pure work hours i know for a fact i put
more hours
working like actual working in this job
than like any previous job
oh easily and it's because you can never
switch off and i think this is the same
war
for every anyone who's like
self-employed where especially
in our position where our jobs
stemmed from our hobby so do you ever
get that point when you're kind of
watching an anime and you can all
reading a manga
and there's just that little voice in
the back of your head that says you can
make a video out of this
you can make a video out of this instead
of just like reading it for what you're
enjoying
yeah that's why i've completely over the
last two years or so i've had a complete
anime burnout
yeah just for that like i've stopped
like i'm sure my viewers can easily see
that i have not been talking about
recent anime whatsoever
when people ask hey have you watched
this hey have you watched this recent
stuff i always say
nope nope i'll get to it i'll get to it
because i have that thing of like
i could just watch this for my own
entertainment yeah but at the same time
i feel like i'm wasting my time
if i don't make a video on it yeah right
that's
i don't know that's that's my biggest
fear is just wasting time yeah i don't
know like whenever i feel like i'm
wasting time i just can't
lose myself in like any show or
something right and i
this it's up to like for anime
that's times 10 because i can never just
watch an anime
just for purely watching an anime
anymore right and that's what that's
made watching anime and reading manga 10
times harder because
if i feel like i don't get anything out
of this either like for entertainment
wise or if i something i can't talk
about
or something like that then i just can't
focus
can't get myself to focus on it but yeah
but
like recently i just watched the good
place which is like a live action show
on netflix
watch live action yeah i did something i
hadn't done in a long time and i watched
all four seasons in like a few days
i'm like what the [ __ ] did i just do how
did i
i didn't know i had this in me remember
when i watched one piece in like two
weeks
my god it's weird because i think
the hardest part is like when i used to
work at mcdonald's
and i used to go home and i got to watch
anime or play video games yeah it was it
was just like
totally different i didn't have to worry
about mcdonald's you didn't have to
second guess right like you could just
be like yeah
immediately like i'm watching yeah yeah
yeah yeah i think the hard part about
burnout is that instead of like the job
being it's difficult
itself is that it creeps into every
aspect of your life
like because youtubers are more often
than not themselves
is the product like yeah we're like the
brand if you will
you know like even just if i go out for
a meal i'm like hmm
am i wasting potential by not posting
about this and
yeah yeah yeah it's like everything in
your life
is like infected with this this thought
of like should i try and monetize this
it's it's
the point where everything in your life
becomes a commodity
even experiences like even experiences
can become a commodity or like in our
cases it could become like
a nice fun story on trash taste and that
kind of thing right where everything
everything
you start thinking about everything in
your life in terms of your job and how
it can
affect your affect your youtube or how
how you can use that to benefit
and it gets to a point sometimes where
it just it just becomes subconscious
which is why i never understood the
mentality of people who do like
daily vlogs of their lives my god how do
you how do you do that i think you have
to be a psychopath yeah i think you do
you have to be psychopathic or
sociopathic or a combination i mean you
you definitely lose something right yeah
like
my relationship with anime and manga has
forever been changed like i still love
anime and manga but my relationship with
it
has been forever changed because that to
me
is content yeah to me is my job it's
work material like imagine if your
entire life
was content i mean my god this is why
like all
the like like vlogging couples always
end up breaking up right because yeah of
course you can
break up because your whole relationship
is the youtube channel
yeah your whole relationship is
determined by the algorithm right